welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the trailer for season five of
Black Mara has just dropped and there's
a lot to unpack from it throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the upcoming
three episodes who stars in them and
what I think they'll be about this is
full spoilers ahead so if you want to go
into the show as blind as possible then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my black mirror season 5
trailer breakdown okay so the first
thing you need to know about season 5 of
black mirror is that it releases
worldwide on Netflix on June 5th this is
a slightly shorter season in the
previous lot with the show only running
for three episodes in total the season
is clearly technology-focused with
smartphones playing a big part and it's
definitely deconstructing society as a
whole the first episode stars Andrew
Scott who seems to be sick of
civilization and after taking a boy
hostage has become a fugitive Scott's
character is fed up of the way that
people are constantly on their phones
and is doing something dramatic in order
to hopefully lift people's heads above
their screens though they actually seem
to be more bothered about filming the
action in front of them I think this
will be interesting as I'm always
annoyed by people I see how and about
sitting together a restaurant something
where you can tell they're not really
talking to each other and are both just
lost in social media so this is
definitely something that can relate to
just not the whole taking people hostage
thing yeah that's bad anyway the second
episode stars Anthony Mackie who gets
caught by his wife looking at pictures
of girls with his friend on his phone
this is clearly a comment on Instagram
and photoshopped images with the
opposite sex always appearing perfect
you to felt is and such and how in real
life things don't really happen like
that I definitely think this is a
much-needed episode as body image and
relationship dissatisfaction can often
be blamed on social media and the amount
of fakeness that goes into it the third
episode stars Miley Cyrus who is
superstar and has released $1 attempts
to raise people's self-esteem by talking
to them this is obviously a commentary
on how people compare themselves with
celebrities and think that their lives
are lacking and how idolization can
provide a lot of negativity in one's
life that becomes hard to get over all
in all I think it looks like a great
season and I can't wait to see what
issues it tackles Black Mirror has
always been phenomenal and it deals with
subjects with respect in ways that I
think that shows like The Twilight Zone
don't obviously I'd love to your
thoughts on the trailer and if you took
anything else from it comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full trailer breakdown of
it chapter 2 which would be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]
you